bloodshed in myanmar continues to
escalate after more than a hundred
civilians were
gunned down by security forces in the
deadliest weekend since february's
military coup
local reports now say aerial attacks
were launched against the karen ethnic
minority driving thousands across the
border with thailand
the u.s and other countries have
condemned the killings as
mass murder and you can understand why
lucy kraft reports now
from tokyo as myanmar's military
celebrated its annual
armed forces day with a parade of
hardware
[Music]
it declared open season on the country's
civilians
even school children killed at home in a
frenzy of state-sponsored violence
as civil disobedience continued to
protest the military's seizing of power
social media circulated this drawing by
eleven-year-old
aimee thu buried with her along with her
toys
activists say over 100 civilians were
killed on saturday alone
with thousands more detained or charged
despite the carnage
strongman general min online was seen
whining and dining at a gala dinner
myanmar's brutal crackdown drew
international condemnation
including from president biden it's
terrible
it's absolutely outrageous and based on
the reporting i've gotten an awful lot
of people have been killed
totally unnecessarily human rights
researcher mounty maung
said the soldiers see themselves as
victims and
quite frankly they're brainwashed what's
going on in their minds is that they're
not doing anything wrong
with both sides unlikely to back down
observers fear more bloodshed
is inevitable for cbs this morning lucy
kraft
tokyo